الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه هي الاكثر
صرامه تجاه الصين بحسب تصريحات وزيره
التجاره الامريكيه جيناريماندو ولكن
وبينما كانت الوزيره تزور الصين في وقت
سابق من هذا الاسبوع كشف عن هاتف ذكي صيني
جديد دخل الى الاسواق بهدوء واثار اطلاقه
قلقا شديدا في واشنطن من ان العقوبات
الامريكيه فشلت في منع الصين من تحقيق
تقدم تكنولوجي رئيسي تطور يتسق مع تحذيرات
صانعي الرقائق الامريكيين من ان العقوبات
لن توقف الصين بل ستحفزها على مضاعفه
الجهود لبناء بدائل للتكنولوجيا الامريكيه
يمثل الهاتف الذكي الجديد ميت سكسي برو
لشركه هواوي تكنولوجي نموذجا لافتا في
تقدم القدرات التكنولوجيه للصين يضم شريحه
متقدمه بداخله صممت وصنعت في الصين على
الرغم من ضوابه التصدير الامريكيه المرهقه
التي تهدف الى منع الصين من انجاز هذه
القفزه التكنولوجيه ويبدو ان توقيت
الاعلان عن الهاتف اثناء وجود ريموندو في
بكين كان بمثابه عرض للتحدي تحدي ترد
الوزيره الامريكيه عليه الان بالقول ان
بلادها لن تسمح للشركات الامريكيه ببيع
الرقائق الالكترونيه وتقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي المتقدمه للصين
لن نتنازل عن منع بيع الرقائق الالكترونيه
الامريكيه وتقنيات الذكاء الصناعي الاكثر
تطورا للصين والتي تريدها بدورها لجيشها
تقول الاداره الامريكيه ان الرقائق
الالكترونيه المتقدمه هي مساله امن قومي
وتسبق المكاسب الاقتصاديه بينما يرى
الجانب الصيني ان هدف واشنطن هو ابطاء
عمليات الاختراع الصينيه فيما يعتقد خبراء
ان خطوه واشنطن الاخيره يمكن ان تعرقل جهد
الصين لتطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي وانواع
اخرى من الحوسبه المتقدمه يبدو ان التنافس
الصيني الامريكي سوف يكون سيمه الثابته
للمرحله المقبله في العلاقات الدوليه لكن
المحللين يرون انه لن يتطور الى صدام مسلح
فمثل هذه النتيجه ستكون مدمره لكلا
البلدين وللدول العالم الاخرى